j'ouvre tout de suite notre second débat
je vous propose de parler de l'avenir
politique de Donald Trump après son
inculpation la semaine dernière par un
tribunal fédéral pour détention
illégales de
documents classifiés pourra-t-il se
présenter à l'élection présidentielle et
sa procès politique comme la firme
l'ancien président américain comment les
électeurs et le parti républicain là-bas
réagissent à ce nouvel épisode
judiciaire avant d'en débattre Flora
sauvage nous rappelle où en sont les
affaires et les rivaux de Trump
faut témoignage en travaillant justice
rétention d'informations portant sur la
sécurité nationale accusée d'avoir
conservé de manière illégale des
documents confidentiels à son départ de
la Maison Blanche Donald Trump est le
premier ex président américain à être
inculpé par la justice candidat à la
présidentielle de 2024 le milliardaire
de 76 ans a comparé mardi dernier devant
le Tribunal fédéral de Miami il appelait
des noms coupables et accuse son
successeur démocrate Joe Biden
de pouvoir c'est très triste d'avoir un
président corrompu en exercice a fait
arrêter son principal adversaire
politique sur la base d'accusation
fausse et fabriquée de toutes pièces
dont lui-même est de nombreux autres
présidents seraient coupables c'est de
l'ingérence électorale une nouvelle
tentative de truquer et de voler une
élection présidentielle de l'immobilier
dénonce une chasse aux sorcières visant
à entraver sa candidature à la prochaine
présidentielle selon cette expert en
politique cette affaire pourrait avoir
un impact sur les chances de Donald
Trump de devenir le candidat des
républicains à la présidence je pense
qu'il est tout à fait possible que vous
ayez un jury qui le condamne et alors
oui il finirait probablement en prison
ensuite les questions commencent à se
poser sur ce qui se passeraient s'il
était élu président depuis une prison
que se passerait-il le président peut-il
se gracier lui-même il n'y a pas de
réponse claire à cette question parce
que les auteurs de la Constitution n'ont
jamais pensé à cette éventualité chez
les républicains quelques voies
discordantes commencent à s'élever
contre Donald Trump mais l'ex-président
malgré les affaires garde une solide
base électorale
on débat de l'avenir de Donald Trump et
de ses affaires judiciaires avec Anne de
Zine bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
professeur des universités juristes
auteurs de ce livre les États-Unis et la
démocratie on est en plein dedans publié
aux éditions l'Harmattan en dialose
bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
avocat franco-américain président de
républicains oversis France et à
l'international pour présenter donc des
républicains expatriés on va dire ça
comme ça ils Achel bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes professeur de sciences
politiques à l'Université Paris Nanterre
et rédactrice en chef de la revue
politique américaine en duplex avec nous
j'accueille Olivier python avocat en
droit public américain bonsoir bienvenue
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
et je cite votre livre
cette biographie de Kamal Harris la
pionnière de l'Amérique publie aux
éditions plomb et Mathieu croissanto
évidemment est resté à mes côtés on va
on va démarrer un désigne sur cette
dernière affaire cette nouvelle
inculpation première dans l'histoire
américaine en quoi je répond la question
mais en quoi était le différente ou plus
grave que les autres pour Donald Trump
lorsque est sorti l'incubation à New
York c'est vrai que la surprise était
générale car
les chaînes que à part vouloir mettre
fin à l'impunité il y avait pas vraiment
d'explications là les chefs sont
beaucoup plus lourd et il y a énormément
d'éléments de preuves mais avec deux
choses à souligner quand même la
première la bonne nouvelle ça ne fait
sans doute pas plaisir aux républicains
mais c'est que le procureur spécial Jack
Smith et le ministre de la justice sont
bien conscients des risques de division
sont bien conscients de la
désinformation des mensonges mais ils
ont décidé de passer outre pour mettre
fin à l'impunité faut se rappeler qu'il
y a pas eu de sanction après les
sécessionnistes durant la guerre de
Sécession il n'y a pas eu de sanction
pour Dixon puisqu'il a été gracié par
Ford et quelque part il s'est instauré
un climat d'impunité donc quelque part
inculper cela veut dire on veut mettre
fin cette situation malgré les risques
et y compris les risques de violence il
y en a et la deuxième chose c'est que
certes il y a beaucoup d'éléments et
c'est incroyable l'acte d'accusation est
inouï moi j'ai jamais vu ça il y a des
photos pour bien montrer que que les
documents confidentiels sont stockés
dans des salles de bains des salles de
balles il y a aussi des tas de passages
où ce sont des extraits de SMS pour
montrer les relations entre le coup
inculpé naruta qui était en fait l'homme
de main l'homme a tout faire de Trump et
Trump lui-même et donc il y a des
éléments de preuves maintenant comment
le procureur va-t-il pouvoir administrer
ses preuves parce que la grande
difficulté c'est que sur les 37 chefs
d'incubation 31 correspondent à 31
documents confidentiels mais il y a des
règles bien précises parce qu'il va pas
pouvoir montrer ses documents
confidentiels au jury et même il y a une
règle bien précise qui dit que il faut
au moins qu'un des avocats de Trump et
la créditation secret défense sinon on
ne peut pas lui montrer les documents et
donc si aucun d'entre nous là ça va être
pas béni pour l'équipe 30 car ils vont
dire ah ben on peut pas prêt et ça va
jouer dans leur stratégie de mesure
dilatoires et de tenir le temps le plus
le plus possible on dit à l'autre vous
parlez la justice politique pourquoi les
justices politiques commencent par aussi
les questions de savoir qui amené ces
différentes
enquêtes en cours on met en parallèle
une situation
qui est
aberrante qu'on voit au sein du comité
par mené par la républicain qui a en
enquête qui dure depuis 5 mois contre
Monsieur Biden et qui montre vraiment
des problèmes sérieux des groupes
anciennes de la famille des Biden il
parle des oligarques ça c'est le même
jour qui disposera d'un enregistrements
entre byeden il y aura deux
enregistrements des Biden et 15
enregistrements avec des fils
concernant un trafic d'influence et un
échange des millions de dollars par
rapport à ses affaires aujourd'hui
je reviens des suit parce que on ne fait
rien ces éléments ils sont entre les
mains de FBI depuis quatre ou cinq ans
et on n'agit pas par rapport à ces
différents problèmes on les cache et
aujourd'hui les problématiques des
documents confidentiels il faut revenir
et j'aimerais que vous mangez des
experts ici qu'on met des choses dans
leur contexte Madame Clinton messieurs
binding dispose de 1850 boîtes des
documents confidentiels qui étaient
sénateur vise président et disposait pas
des autres réalisations pour amener ces
documents chez lui il a dans ses garages
il les a à l'université de textis et des
pins souvenirs il a des documents à
l'université des dealware on se trouve
dans un système de justice que ça
s'applique astuces opposant politique
mais quand il s'agit de Madame Clinton
aussi les directeurs de pierre à décidé
de ne pas poursuivre Madame Clinton
quand il y avait des soucis aussi par
rapport document pardon donc vous nous
dites grosso modo il y a des affaires
similaires qui concernent Hillary
Clinton ou Joe Biden alors voilà
l'obstruction c'est-à-dire le fait Biden
mais dès qu'il a été au courant il a
rendu les documents là il a fallu que
les archives le FBI augmente les
sanctions alors qu'ils étaient au début
très courtois très plein de différences
et finissent par obtenir qu'une
perquisition soit validée par un juge
pour aller à marego et entre-temps Trump
avait fait sortir certains des documents
par l'homme de main en question pour
être sûr que même son avocat ne voit pas
les documents donc les points
je vous redonnerai la parole plus tard
je vais faire en sorte que tout le monde
puisse s'expliquer sur sur ce plateau je
rappelle c'est la résidence de Donald
Trump ils achènent est-ce que pour
répondre peut-être à ce que ce que
disait en dialose est-ce qu'il y a une
justice c'est une sorte de justice à
deux vitesses que vous nous décrivez
est-ce que vous diriez ça en ce moment
aux États-Unis non je ne dirais pas
qu'il y a de justice à du vitesses je
dirais que le parti républicain comme le
Parti démocrate savent et les
républicains et les démocrates savent
instrumentaliser la justice quand ils
sont au pouvoir donc on est aux
États-Unis dans une société où les
relations sociales sont très fortement
judiciaires judiciar pardon donc à tous
les niveaux donc oui il y a beaucoup de
conflits qui se règle dans les tribunaux
et la justice est aussi une arène
d'affrontements politiques donc je
dirais qu'il n'y a rien de
particulièrement surprenant dans cette
affaire Olivier python je viens vers
vous une première fois peut-être pour
nous nous expliquer que ce procès il
devrait avoir lieu en Floride alors
est-ce que c'est qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire est-ce que c'est forcément est-ce
que c'est une bonne ou une mauvaise
nouvelle pour Donald Trump a priori
alors c'est bien parce que vous avez eu
un concentré de la situation aux
États-Unis telle qu'elle existe à
l'heure actuelle c'est-à-dire que vous
avez un clivage tellement important que
vous avez deux camps qui ne se qui ne se
reconnaissent même plus la légitimité de
pouvoir parler clairement de la
situation et ce qui se dit est assez
symptomatique de la crise démocratique
que vit actuellement les États-Unis il
faut bien comprendre quelque chose ce
contexte il est extrêmement explosif et
la délégitimisation de de la parole
judiciaire aux Etats-Unis est
extrêmement importante et ça permet
aussi de comprendre ce qui est en train
de se passer pour répondre clairement à
votre question il y a un procureur
spécial qui a été nommé pourquoi un
procureur spécial a-t-il été nommé tout
simplement parce que le président des
États-Unis est en le chef de
l'administration on a un conflit
d'intérêt si un de ses serviteurs donc
en l'occurrence ça procureur menait une
enquête contre son boss donc on a
effectivement un procureur spécial qui a
été quand même nommé par un ministre de
Joe Biden Americ Garland et qui fait son
travail et il le fait de manière on
parle de Jack Smith il le fait de
manière plutôt habile jusqu'à présent
puisqu'en fait il a décidé que le procès
en tout cas une partie du procès à
l'échelon fédéral se déroulerait en
Floride qui est le lieu de résidence de
Donald Trump et là où les documents ont
été
entreposés donc les fameux les fameux
documents confidentiels que Donald Trump
a récupéré et donc à partir de ce
moment-là le jury en Floride est
considéré comme étant sans doute plus en
tout cas moins défavorable à Donald
Trump puisque la Floride est plutôt un
état très de très peu majoritairement
républicains maintenant sur le sur le
fond je voulais revenir en une seconde
sur ce qui avait dit l'interlocuteur
américain qui avait été interviewé on
est dans un hommagement judiciaire total
on ne sait pas du tout ce qui va se
passer on ne sait même pas si Donald
Trump ira un jour en prison et s'il va
en prison ne sait même pas s'il pourra
ou non se retrouver en incapacité de de
se présenter d'être élu puisqu'il y a
que deux États aux États-Unis qui
empêchent de pouvoir voter c'est le
Vermont et le main dans tous les autres
États des États-Unis vous pouvez vous
présenter tout en étant détenus détenues
et être élu président des États-Unis en
tout cas on est dans un flou qui permet
effectivement ce genre de choses donc il
faut être extrêmement prudent et c'est
ce qui rend le c'est ce qui rend le sel
de cette affaire tout à fait passionnant
alors je vous propose d'entendre tout de
suite une une première action celle de
l'ancien président comment a-t-il réagi
à cette inculpation fédérale en
attaquant Joe Biden le plus important
encore il s'agit d'une persécution
politique digne d'une nation fasciste ou
communiste ce jour restera infâme et Joe
Biden restera à jamais dans les mémoires
comme étant non seulement le président
le plus corrompu de l'histoire de notre
pays mais peut-être plus important
encore le président qui avait qu'une
bande de voyous de marginaux et de
marxiste qui lui sont proches a tenté de
détruire la démocratie américaine
Mathieu vous êtes frappé par la
stratégie de défense de Donald Trump moi
je vois ça de ce côté de l'Atlantique
mais je trouve que contre vents et
marées celui-ci n'en démord pas et quel
que soit l'affaire on pourrait la
résumer sa stratégie de défense à un
vieux principe connu de tous les
habitués du crime organisé n'avoue
jamais or cette stratégie elle peut se
révéler périlleuse peut-être sur le plan
judiciaire encore plus lorsque il y a
des aimants factuels tel qu'on le voit
là dans cette affaire des documents
classifiés puisque les documents ont été
retrouvés chez lui on connaît les pièces
où ils ont été retrouvés ça sera
peut-être difficile difficile de dire
qu'il n'y était pas mais j'ai
l'impression qu'elle se révèle plutôt
payante sur le du point de vue politique
en tout cas pour le moment en tout cas
ça ne le laisse pas ça ne le handicap
pas ça lui permet de préserver son image
auprès de ses fans après son incubation
tient dans l'affaire du paiement de
stormy Daniel's et ben il a même fait un
bon dans les sondages républicains au
mois d'avril deux tiers des électeurs
interrogés par USA déclarait que la
situation juridique de l'ancien
président ne faisait pas de différence
et 27% d'entre eux déclaraient que ça
les inciterait même à le soutenir
davantage encore comment on peut
l'expliquer ça à chaque fois une
collecte plusieurs millions de dollars
exactement la Floride alors à mes yeux
parce que cette stratégie de défense et
on l'a un peu dit ce double d'une
opération de victimisation répétée en
boucle sur les estrades comme sur les
plateaux par lui-même comme par ses
soutiens Donald Trump ferait l'objet
d'une chasse aux sorcières ça c'est ce
qu'il dit depuis que Joe Biden lui a
volé l'élection si je résume pour des
téléspectateurs français théorie du
complot installé dès le soir même de de
l'élection de son adversaire la Maison
Blanche et désormais glisser dans
l'esprit des partisans de Donald Trump
qui reste imperméable à toutes les
révélations qui ont pu surgir depuis et
qui remettent du coup en cause toute
parole officielle et même on vient de le
dire et que les python toutes paroles
judiciaires ce qui moi à mes yeux de
français pose une question comment la
démocratie américaine qui onise
seulement songe qui était autrefois
capable de faire tomber n'importe quel
candidat pour le moins de petit
arrangements avec la vérité fusse un
joint fumé sur un campus de l'université
ou une infidélité conjugale mais comment
cette démocratie américaine a-t-elle pu
se laisser gangrener par autant de fake
news comment le pays du Watergate a pu
devenir à ce point celui de la
désinformation
on sait que Clinton a menti et c'était
très important là on a la différence
entre les mensonges dans les meetings à
la télévision pour lesquels il n'y a pas
de sanction mais là nous allons
justement devant le tribunal et si Trump
devait témoigner ce serait sous serment
et là c'est une autre affaire mais cette
désinformation elle est due aux réseaux
sociaux mais elle est due aussi au fait
que le premier amendement protège une
liberté d'expression totale et en
conséquence il n'y a aucun moyen de
sanctionner les mensonges parce que les
conférences de presse les prises de
parole de Donald Trump sont une
succession de mensonges et ça a commencé
bien avant la perte de l'élection parce
qu'il y a eu le rapport mulaire
l'enquête et puis les deux mises en
accusation publique
c'est mentir devant la justice et là
puisque ce n'est pas devant la justice
ils disent n'importe quoi et c'est la
raison on voit bien que les avocats par
exemple on refuse de dire certaines
choses refusent de signer des acides
disant qu'ils ont vu tous les cartons
etc parce que eux savent que tout ce qui
a une valeur juridique là le mensonge
peut leur faire évidemment ce que vous
venez de dire fait réagir dans oui c'est
normal que je réagis ce que j'entends
c'est déjà un procès d'intention pas
nous inviter mon collègue à droite dit
que il est digne des crimes organisés il
n'a vu jamais et de l'autre côté tout ce
qui sort de la bouche de Monsieur Trump
est un mensonge après mensonge et
mensonge peut-être on devrait regarder
un peu les journalistes qu'on fait du
nombre de mensonges
mais moi je vous dis ce qui se passe
quand il était au lot 2016 vous avez
l'administration les campagnes de Madame
Clinton et c'est les mêmes l'enquête
Newloc a montré qu'ils ont monté les
dossiers contre Mister Trump c'est toute
l'affaire Russie a été montée et on sait
bien c'est un montage et vous pouvez
nier tout ça et essayer ils ont fait ils
ont procédé pour faire un empêchement
sur cette base tout le monde savait que
c'était faux même les FBI les
départements de justice a été critiqué
par l'enquête qui était menée mais on
parle de mensonges sans conséquences il
y avait personne dans le dans la
campagne des cliniques qui a été
sanctionné ni poursuivi dans cette
affaire donc c'est très facile de
vouloir dire ces trempe c'est les
républicains mais les démocrates sont
jamais sanctionnés il y a jamais des
poursuites on a l'affaire de Monsieur
Biden vous et vous dites rien sur des
affaires des des problèmes avec l'oligan
ukrainien et qui est ce nom et qu'il a
vendu des affaires non oui aujourd'hui
on en a faire très sérieuse qu'on a un
monsieur qui est le président des
États-Unis qui est
d'avoir fait un trafic d'influence des
pays non aminux
elle les donne pas et qui cache des
informations donc c'est plus facile à
parler aujourd'hui de Monsieur Trump qui
est plus facile de vouloir tourner tout
votre attention on a compris
l'argumentation consiste à dire c'est
parlons pas de Donald Trump parlons
plutôt des des démocrates Trump aurait
pu alors Clinton vous vous vouliez
intervenir oui j'aurais souhaité réagir
sur la stratégie qui a été évoquée la
stratégie de se présenter comme victime
alors effectivement cette stratégie
permet de réactiver sa base électorale
qui le soutient mais jusqu'à présent les
affaires stormy Daniel et Jean Carole
n'ont pas fait bouger beaucoup les
opinions c'est à dire que ces soutiens
le continuait de le soutenir
là avec cette affaire et aussi il faut
penser à celle qui vont venir sur
l'élection de Géorgie et sur l'invasion
du Capitole qui seront jugés plus tard
on a quand même un parti républicain qui
commence à bouger on l'a entendu
différentes voix au sein du parti
commence à se faire entendre pour
s'interroger quant à savoir si
Donald Trump doit être le candidat élu
pendant les primaires donc on a
plusieurs républicains qui se posent
ouvertement à la question des affaires
elles sont plus graves elles sont
beaucoup plus graves de sécurité
nationale on n'est pas dans des phrases
que extra-conjugales et ça c'est après
il y a l'affreux électorale et peut-être
encore une fois c'est à légué mais
peut-être les incitations à
l'insurrection donc ça ce sont des chefs
d'accusation beaucoup plus graves que
des affaires de mœurs on va revenir sur
la question de du Capitole du 6 janvier
mais je voudrais
Olivier python que vous nous parliez
peut-être je reste sur la dernière
incubation de Donald Trump cette affaire
de documents
protégés ou classifier sur quoi repose
la défense de l'ancien président
américain dans ce dossier
alors principalement sur deux piliers le
premier pilier je crois qu'il a été
assez bien abordé par l'ensemble de vos
invités c'est à dire que la meilleure
défense étant l'attaque c'est
effectivement pour Donald Trump et ses
équipes de d'expliquer que le camp d'en
face a fait exactement la même chose
avec des rétentions de documents etc je
vais pas m'étendre là-dessus le deuxième
le deuxième angle de défense de Donald
Trump est fondée plus spécifiquement sur
la fameuse loi de 1978 qui justement
réglemente le le la transmission de ces
documents sensibles ce qui s'appelle le
président show record Act et l'une des
faiblesses en tout cas c'est ce que
prétend le le l'équipe du côté de Trump
c'est d'expliquer qu'il peut lui-même en
tant que président en tout cas à
l'époque dès classifier les documents et
que les documents qu'il a emporté avec
lui en Floride était donc de son propre
fait des classifier n'était donc plus
soumis à cette fameuse loi de 1978
très honnêtement il est impossible de
répondre actuellement à la question de
savoir si la défense est tenable ou pas
puisqu'on a une vraie faille en fait il
y a jamais eu de cas de figure qui se
soit présenté de cette manière là et
donc on va voir ce que vont expliquer
les avocats des deux camps on va voir
la manière dont on va réagir le on va
réagir le jury mais en gros pour résumer
tout le monde fait pareil axe de défense
numéro 1 axe de défense numéro 2 j'ai
des classifié moi-même les documents ils
ne sont donc plus soumis à la loi de
1978 et j'avais le droit de les garder
chez moi on va voir ce que ça va donner
vous voulez intervenir oui sauf qu'il
n'a pas des classifier et on le sait
pertinemment parce que lorsqu'il a
montré à deux reprises des documents
classés défenses à des gens qui
n'avaient pas l'habilitation il a dit et
c'est entendu sur les enregistrements de
la sécurité de son domicile en Floride
il a dit de vous approcher pas trop
parce que c'est secret je n'ai pas le
droit de vous le montrer et il a rajouté
et on s'est capturé sur bande donc on
peut l'entendre
de la propre voix de Monsieur Trump
j'aurais pu déclassifier quand j'étais
Président je ne l'ai pas fait
sous-entendu maintenant c'est trop tard
donc il est conscient qu'il n'a pas des
classifié et il est conscient que ce
sont des secrets que c'était dangereux
de les montrer alors on parlait en
évoquait l'impact de ces de ces dossiers
sur l'électorat républicain je vous
propose d'écouter plusieurs partisans on
en a choisi trois partisans de Donald
Trump qui viennent le soutenir en marge
de cette inculpation en écoute
je suis si heureuse de le voir je veux
que le président Trump soit libre
j'étais très soulagée je veux que toutes
les charges contre Trump soit abandonnés
la grande majorité des gens ici sont là
pour soutenir le président Donald Trump
alors que l'administration byden
instrumentalisent le gouvernement contre
un opposant politique
est-ce que ces affaires renforcent la
popularité de Donald Trump aujourd'hui
auprès de son électorat auprès des
soldatorats même pas par rapport aux
indépendants il y a un augmentation même
parmi les indépendants aux États-Unis
dans le sondage qui se disent ils
veulent pas voir l'Amérique à traiter de
cette manière là quand on souhaite pas
utiliser les systèmes de justice contre
un rival politique parce que c'est son
précédent aujourd'hui ça s'est jamais
passé dans l'histoire de l'Amérique
j'espère qu'on peut partager en moi cela
qui en a pas cet achat en aimant sera un
président qui est dans les élections
compte son opposant et que aujourd'hui
il est numéro un il est au-dessus il
passe devant tous les autres candidats
de très loin et qui a cette
multiplication des procédures qui se
font contre lui et aujourd'hui et c'est
son précédent il y a vraiment une perte
de confiance je dirais déjà chez les
républicains mais je estime aussi qu'il
y a chez les indépendants et c'est ça ce
qui va faire la différence lors de la
prochaine élection dire est-ce qu'il
souhaite avoir un Amérique et une
administration byden et une partie
démocrate qui est instrumentalise les
systèmes de justice à des femmes
politiques et aujourd'hui je dirais non
parce que les sondages le montrent et il
y a déjà une chute parmi ces personnes
vous pouvez regarder fait vos propres
recherches et vous allez pouvoir
constater cela et est-ce
qu'effectivement parce que là il y a une
course à la primaire républicaine qui
est lent qui est lancé est-ce qu'on voit
le l'écart entre Donald Trump et c'est
poursuivants se creuser au rythme de ses
affaires alors non c'est parce que
montre les dernières enquêtes run De
Santis et derrière lui crise Christie
qui a alors deux il faudrait spécifier
De Santis à une difficulté de
positionnement c'est qu'il il convoite
le même électorat que Trump et Chris
Christie en revanche ses positionné
plutôt sur la conquête de l'électorat
modéré effectivement ce sont les modérée
et les indépendants qui feront cette
élection les électeurs on va dire
protrump le reste mais il ne faut pas
oublier que si Trump a gagné 2016 le
corps républicain aussi perdu en 2018 en
2020 en 2022 donc le parti se demande
vraiment qui pourrait prendre la relève
pour gagner cette élection et on va en
parler tout de suite avec Quentin dans
une minute avec Quentin calmé mais vous
l'avez évoqué rapidement un désigne sur
le un élément qui est très important
dans une campagne président américaine
qui est l'argent
est-ce que vous nous dites sont très
hors de guerre entre guillemets grossit
au rythme des affaires c'est ça il y a
un très gros trésor de guerre cela étant
de Santis a pas mal d'argent parce qu'il
a des supers packs derrière lui et il a
tous les stabilismes républicains qui
commencent à se dire de Trump est trop
dangereux et je crois oui alors je crois
qu'il y a vraiment deux catégories il y
a la base les 40%, il pourrait tuer
quelqu'un sur la Cinquième Avenue il
l'avait dit et on voit bien ce qui se
passe il y a toutes les inculpations de
la planète et la base continuent de le
soutenir et de payer puis aller
stabilisement qui commence à paniquer
même Bilba qui a été un soudé
inconditionnel dit si ne serait-ce que
la moitié des charges sont vraies il est
ta hostile fichu où il est cuit alors
l'argent oui mais en fait il y a pas
seulement l'argent que collecte les
candidats il y a aussi tout cet argent
qu'on appelle opaque dark money ils sont
collectés par des groupes qu'on ne
connaît pas bien parce qu'ils n'ont pas
besoin de divulguer qui donne l'argent
etc et qui vont financer des dizaines de
millions de publicités électorales et
donc on ne sait pas encore très bien où
va aller cet argent est-ce que si on
voit le mouvement qui continue et je
sais pas si vous seriez content si
Monsieur Trump est investi par le parti
République
aujourd'hui et les autres candidats ni
le même chose et considère il faut les
rappeler vous avez monsieur De Santis
vous êtes tous les autres chroniques et
dit la même chose ils estiment que les
systèmes judiciaires et instrumentalisés
attendez je vais juste
campagne sur l'incubation il pourrait
collecter des millions de dollars lui
aussi en se posant contre Trump et
contre l'incubation et pour montrer
qu'il est distinct du processus
judiciaire il ne le fait pas donc il a
quand même quelque part une certaine
intégrité on va s'intéresser pardon de
vous interrompre on va s'intéresser d'un
peu plus près aux autres candidats
républicains grâce à Quentin calmer
bonsoir Quentin bienvenue de nouveau sur
ce plateau donc avec quelques critiques
contre Donald Trump qui commence à
s'exprimer au sein du parti républicain
voilà les voix dissidentes étaient
jusque-là discrète elles se font de plus
en plus nombreuses les poursuites
judiciaires envers Donald Trump vont
être au cœur on le comprend de la
campagne des primaires républicaines qui
va s'étaler sur les six prochains mois
chacun des candidats actuellement à
Lisses pour la nomination au grenthol
party doit se prononcer désormais sur
son inculpation et en fait ils sont une
dizaine un 12 ou 13 selon politique pour
cette nomination d'un exemple en date
Mike pence il était pourtant très proche
de Donald Trump même s'il avait pris ses
distances ces derniers mois mais c'est
lui qui a été son vice-président pendant
les quatre ans écoutez-le dans une
interview diffusée hier sur NBC News
tout d'abord personne n'est au-dessus de
la loi deuxièmement chaque Américain a
droit à la présomption d'innocence mais
j'ai lu les chefs d'accusation en
détails
sont sérieuses et je ne peux pas le
défendre pour ce dont il est accusé mais
l'ancien président a droit à un procès
il a droit à l'opportunité de se
défendre face à la justice
cette déclaration fait grand bruit Mike
pence qui est crédité de 4% d'intention
de vote dans un récent sondage il se
sert de cette sortie aussi pour exister
dans la course qu'effectivement Donald
Trump survole pour l'heure l'ancien
président américain qui est crédité de
53% d'attention de vote chez les
républicains la majorité des candidats
en revanche Thomas elle refuse plutôt
d'accabler le favori de la course
regardez trois exemples vous avez run De
Santis alors lui il est crédité il est
tout à gauche crédité de 23% Nicky
allais 4% ou encore et bien le troisième
vivait Rama shwami il a aussi lui doté
de 3% de tension de vote tous les trois
ont déjà évoqué le fait qu'une fois élu
il serait amené à glacier Donald Trump
c'est la procédure du Paraden ils ont
déjà dit qu'ils s'engageraient à le
faire s'ils étaient élus il faut dire
qu'en fait Thomas seul 13% des électeurs
républicains estiment dans un récent
sondage que Donald Trump a commis une
infraction dans l'affaire des documents
top secret mon rendu après qu'il a
quitté la Maison Blanche merci beaucoup
quand on dit allô la déclaration de Mike
pence quand même vice-président
américain pendant quatre ans qui qui
parle de d'alégation grave ça vous fait
pas fléchir un peu dans votre soutien à
Donald Trump moi je dis ce qu'il a dit
il y a la présomption de ta naissance et
j'estime aujourd'hui qui il faut et il
faut faire bien un distinction il fait
son rôle et il joue son rôle idéal c'est
objectif il dit pas à droite il dit pas
à gauche il est au centre aujourd'hui ce
que j'entends ici tout le monde dit oui
il y a presque comme attention des
coupabilités donc sa position
respectable c'est un candidat il garde
sa position il a un cap il souhaite
aussi être à les gagnants du primaire
donc c'est tout à fait respectable sa
position c'est normal donc je n'ai rien
à critiquer par rapport à cela ce qui
est intéressant et je pense qu'on
regarde ce que les cons a républicains
on parle pas de Monsieur Robert Kendrick
junior dans cette affaire là parce que
lui aussi et ça il est donné à 15%
d'intention de vente côté démocrate et
lui il fait les mêmes critiques que les
républicains il dit qu'il a juste à
instantanée vis-à-vis des messieurs
damos Trump donc on entend bien dans les
camps de démocrate quelqu'un qui a place
assez important aujourd'hui dans la
course à présidentielle aujourd'hui
alors il y a évidemment un autre dossier
majeur qui est le dossier de l'attaque
du Capitole le 6 janvier
2021 avec la question de la
responsabilité ou non de Donald Trump
dans le déclenchement de cette
de cette attaque nous évitons est-ce que
toutes ces procédures en cours vous avez
un tout petit peu répondu tout à l'heure
peuvent empêcher Donald Trump de se
représenter la réponse est clairement
non c'est-à-dire qui pourrait même être
en prison il serait quand même candidat
quoi une petite exception près puisqu'on
parle du on parle de l'assaut du
Capitole c'est que si jamais il était
condamné pour haute trahison dans ce cas
là c'est le seul cas de figure il ne
pourrait pas se présenter ou il ne
pourrait pas être élu président des
États-Unis en tous les autres cas de
figure entre les possibilités de recours
et notamment devant la Cour suprême y
compris d'ailleurs pour le cas qui nous
concerne aujourd'hui sur la rétention de
documents sensibles il a tout à fait la
possibilité effectivement de de pouvoir
continuer sa campagne d'ailleurs c'est
pour cela que moi je me limite
simplement à donner des éléments sur sa
défense et non pas à prendre partie tout
simplement parce qu'on ne sait pas ce
qui va se passer il est difficile voire
même impossible de juger aujourd'hui de
l'acceptation ou non des documents qu'il
fournit et de la défense qu'il aura donc
il faut toujours être très très prudent
et très mesuré ce qui explique de toute
façon ça ça défense c'est que justement
son intérêt de durée pourquoi son
intérêt est Dedieu parce que ça a été
dit par un certain nombre de de
personnes et d'intervenants il est
renforcé auprès de sa base à chaque fois
qu'une affaire judiciaire le concerne
que ce soit les affaires au civil ou au
pénal avec l'État de New York on en a
parlé tout à l'heure où ce soit la faire
actuel et on verra ce que ça donnera
pour le pour la faire de l'assaut du
Capitole il a aujourd'hui entre 20 et 30
points d'avance c'est ce qui a montré
votre sondage et tous les sondages
montrent la même chose il a aujourd'hui
entre 20 et 30 points d'avance sur
l'ensemble des candidats républicains et
deuxième élément à prendre en
considération l'ensemble des ténors
républicains qui prennent la parole
aujourd'hui de manière d'ailleurs très
mesurée à l'exception de Chris
christique et le celui qui a étalé le
plus loin mais ils sont tous extrêmement
mesurés mais tout simplement parce
qu'ils sont en campagne contre lui et
donc leurs paroles a quand même aussi
auprès d'électorat républicain du mal à
percer puisqu'ils sont en concurrence
avec Donal Trump il est difficile
aujourd'hui de considérer qu'il y ait
une parole républicaine antitrope même
si on sait que depuis 2015 2016 les
sablishmane républicain et
structurellement opposé à Donald Trump
mais c'est pas le cas de la base et la
base le montre encore aujourd'hui alors
ça répond à un peu à la question que
j'allais vous poser parce que vu d'ici
on se dit pourquoi le parti républicain
avec cette cette longue tradition ne
peut pas tourner la page Donald Trump
alors qui attend à faire alors déjà rien
n'est fait c'est on est encore dans une
période de campagne les primaires n'ont
pas encore commencé elles ne commencent
quand au mois de janvier donc faudra
attendre pour savoir pour dire si cette
page se tourne ou non après il y a après
le 6 janvier après l'attaque du Capitole
c'est moi j'ai encore une fois
j'assume mes maigres connaissances de la
politique américaine comparée à votre
expertise aux uns et aux autres mais à
ce moment-là pourquoi le parti
républicain dit pas mais voilà plus
jamais Tru la décision la décision se
fait par un vote pendant les primaires
donc de toute façon il faut que les
primaires s'ouvrent se passent et puis
il faut aussi que la justice fasse son
travail
les il faut dire un mot des temporalités
de ces procès elles sont extrêmement
longues le procès sur les documents
classifiés ils ne commencera pas avant
l'année prochaine pour des raisons qui
sont liées à au fonctionnement de la
justice le procès sur l'invasion du
Capitole encore plus tard donc on est
aussi sur des temporalités extrêmement
longues et le parti républicain pourra
très bien décider si ces électeurs se
prononcent dans ce sens de ce de se
séparer de Donald Trump mais on n'est
pas dans un système de désignation en
fait donc on peut pas
ça va commencer par les coccus dans la
yowa au moins au mois de janvier juste
quand vous dites les procédures sont
longues ça peut être après le scrutin
présidentiel
à toutes les décisions ne seront pas
rendues d'ici novembre 2024 c'est
certain surtout que les affaires qui le
concernent votre analyse là-dessus parce
que le parti républicain considère que
c'est peut-être encore aujourd'hui le
mieux placé pour l'emporter c'est ce que
tu as fait ça c'est que
candidat aimerait bien que Trump
disparaisse se débarrasser de lui mais
il y a de nouveau voter pour lui donc on
va avoir le calendrier des idées là et
comme le système du côté républicain
c'est pas la même chose du côté
démocrate c'est à la majorité donc si
Trump l'emporte dans la loi juste d'un
petit chouïa il remporte tous les
délégués de la loi même chose dans tous
les états et donc il est très possible
que simplement poussé par sa base
personne ne puisse vraiment percer sauf
dans certains États et les candidats qui
sont opposés à lui n'osent pas le
critiquer ouvertement sauf que c'était
et à sachasson parce qu'ils ont besoin
de la base donc ils sont un petit peu
dans un système impossible mais ce qui
est ce qui est important c'est la
temporalité parce qu'effectivement même
ceux-là nous avons l'incubation mais
compte tenu de la difficulté de produire
les documents confidentiels etc
nous sommes dans la phase qu'on appelle
Discovery investigation de la cause
c'est-à-dire le procureur doit
transmettre à la défense les éléments à
charge sauf qu'il peut pas les
transmettre tout de suite s'il y a un
avocat n'a pas la créditation donc ça va
prendre très très longtemps donc dans la
meilleure des hypothèses la première
audience aura lieu dans 9 mois et il y
aura tout un tas de motions par le
contrat disant mais on veut passer cela
et un autre élément c'est que la juge à
qui a été attribué le cas c'est un
tirage au sort c'est la juge qui annule
qui a déjà statué sur l'affaire des
documents il y a quelques mois elle est
très jeune elle a 42 ans elle a aucune
expérience en matière de procédure
pénale elle a été nommée donc par Trump
en 2020 et il y a quelques mois
lorsqu'il y a eu la perquisition de Marc
Lago Trump et ses avocats en dire non
non il faut pas que le FBI regarde les
documents ils ont saisi la justice là
jusqu'à non instatuer en disant oui
quand même il est président il faut
nommer ce qu'on appelle un Special
master donc un tiers indépendant sauf
qu'elle a été déjuguée par le 11e sur
qui par la cour d'appel donc là on voit
que cette juge elle est pas très au
courant des procédures pénales elle est
sans doute pro-trope mais elle a rendu
compte que elle ne pouvait pas faire
exactement ce que vous voulez
se préparer en dialogue c'est une
campagne
des primaires du Parti républicain qui
sera finalement rythmée par les affaires
judiciaires ça va être ça va être le
feuilleton permanent
ça peut être dans le deux sens ça vous
désalpe aussi ça va dépendre comme vous
le voyez vous pouvez imaginer ça peut
être intacter que si on ceux qui
considère que la justice est un stop
mentalisée qui est
occupé les terrains c'est Dieu qui doit
être préoccupé par ses affaires
judiciaires il va pas pouvoir se
concentrer sur ses compagnies
électorales donc il y a de l'autre côté
ça aussi c'est aussi doit aller chaque
mois tous les deux semaines devant un
juge dans tel ou telle affaire donc il
aura pas de temps pour faire la campagne
donc ça vous pouvez l'entendre de
l'autre côté ou si il faut comprendre
que on en affaire sur la confidentialité
pour voir accès il faut qu'il soit
autorisé agréable pour avoir accès mais
il y a tout un autre problématique c'est
le FBI vous avez les jurer etc à quel
niveau et c'est qui décidé de donner
cette accès à quel niveau d'accès c'est
l'administration Biden ce n'est pas les
juges qui les décidons c'est encore
c'est un aspect politisé qui donne cet
autorisation et à différents niveaux et
à quel niveau des divulgations de ces
documents on peut facilement cacher une
partie des éléments dans ce document
dire je fournis un résumé mais non c'est
pas suffisant il y aura un débat sur
chaque document pour faire un objet de
discussions pendant des mois et des mois
donc aujourd'hui on est un confronté à
cette difficulté procédurale j'ai une
toute petite question pourquoi il les a
pris chez lui ces documents tous les
présidents et il faut savoir ça
s'appelle les narration
j'ai oublié les noms
c'est une organisation qui gère toutes
les archives et tous les présidents ont
droit et l'administration a prévu toute
une façon qui avec chaque président qui
peuvent c'est là où il y a à condition
d'avoir des classifié avant de les avant
de les enfants
cela bien entendu et ils sont aussi un
question de toute une façon de
d'organiser mais à disposition des
présidents souvent ils aient un endroit
pour les classer et que c'était pas le
cas du président Trump il y avait une
difficulté de chaque président était
suivi par l'administration donc il y
aura certains éléments certaines
questions aujourd'hui c'est un élément
de fer on n'est pas d'accord je parle
des battre de culpabilité et la question
la loi c'est une loi 1978 qui a été voté
parce que Nixon voulait emporter les
cassettes du Watergate et donc le
Congrès a dit non il faut que les
présidents remettent au peuple américain
tout ce qui concerne la présidence pour
la recherche pour l'histoire et cetera
donc en vertu de cette loi et là je
parle même pas de documents confidentiel
un président qui s'en va doit remettre
tous les documents sauf ces personnes
qui machin à lui il les garde mais même
une note de peu d'intérêt c'est bon pour
l'histoire les historiens vont regarder
dans 30 ans etc et c'est ça la loi si on
achètent c'est tout il y a une autre loi
qui elle traite des documents
confidentiels à laquelle je faisais
allusion en disant qu'il faudra
effectivement les avocats se conforment
aux critères qui sont prévus
ces documents mais comme j'ai expliqué
auparavant il y avait certaines comme
même pendant le président maintenant
qu'il était sénateur monsieur Biden
n'avait pas même ces autorisations pas
eu le droit d'apporter ces documents
chez lui vous dites ah il a fait une
négligence non légalement il n'avait pas
le droit de les faire il n'a aucune
autorisation c'est pas le président des
États-Unis à l'époque à aller alors on
termine avec très vite allez aujourd'hui
encore je souhaite que ce soit clair que
aujourd'hui il faut laisser la justice
faire son travail et aujourd'hui
j'espère que au moins on fera la lumière
de ce qui se passe aussi dans les
combats pour qu'il puisse avoir ça on a
entendu cet argument merci proposer
plusieurs fois je vous propose un
dernier élément tiens on va revoir un
extrait d'un des d'un des débats d'un
des duels Trump Biden de la dernière
élection présidentielle une vidéo
réalisée fournie par notre partenaire
loopsider
ils sont toujours au soutien Donald
Trump ils sont ils ont pas été déçus par
par son attitude on en est où là dessus
non c'est pas le fragment de son
électorat qui va être déçu les
déceptions encore une fois sont du côté
des plus modérés qui lui ont fait
confiance en 2016 il avait aussi il faut
se rappeler de son bilan bénéficier
d'une embellie économique qui lui avait
permis d'afficher des résultats tout à
fait satisfaisant donc non c'est frange
radical elles existent depuis longtemps
aux États-Unis elles sont elles sont le
socle de l'électorat de Trump mais ce ne
sont pas ces franges là qui qui font
l'élection véritable Olivier Py c'est un
moment que je vous ai pardonné la parole
on va quasiment conclure ce débat avec
vous est-ce que un remake de 2020 ce
n'est pas ce que souhaite aussi Joe
Biden est-ce que Donald Trump est pas
une certaine façon le meilleur le
meilleur adversaire pour lui alors là
c'est vraiment la question au placard
parce que effectivement
les démocrates ne sont cachent pas
tellement le le candidat idéal selon eux
selon leurs analyses et leur stratège
c'est effectivement que ce soit Donald
Trump qui puisse remporter la primaire
républicaine et pour ceux qui pensent du
côté des du côté des républicains qu'il
y a une instrumentalisation de la
justice on en revient de discussion
précédentes dans le but justement de de
de de de faire prospérer la machine
Trump qui continue à grimper dans les
sondages au fur et à mesure qu'il est
inculpé il y a effectivement proprement
mais on va être très prudent là-dessus
un coup de billard à trois bandes ou les
démocrates ont effectivement intérêt à
attiser les affaires pour que Donald
Trump soit le candidat républicain
au-delà de ça ce qui est peut-être la
grande faiblesse Donald Trump dans cette
affaire c'est que en 2015 en 2016 qu'on
aime qu'on n'aime pas le personnage il
avait mis sur le devant de la scène un
syndrome de questions qui des questions
qui n'avaient plus été abordées dans le
l'Agora américaine depuis un certain
nombre de temps la
désinstruelles la désindustrialisation
pardon le rapport à la mondialisation
le fait qu'un certain nombre de
populations en particulier blanche
paupérisée se sentait mis à l'écart
aujourd'hui finalement au bout du compte
c'est que Donald Trump ne parle plus que
de Donald Trump et les sujets de société
qu'il avait réussi à mettre en avant
durant la campagne de 2015 et de 2016
sont noyés sous une sorte d'égo qui pour
l'instant ne le rendent pas
véritablement audible au-delà de sa base
c'est peut-être ça le principal merci
beaucoup merci à tous Je rappeller
rapidement le titre de vos livres un
design des États-Unis et la démocratie
publiée aux éditions l'Harmattan Olivier
python kamalaris la pionnière de
l'Amérique publiée chez plomb merci à
tous d'avoir participé à ce débat je
vous dis à demain n'oubliez pas que vous
pouvez retrouver le programme sur la
plateforme public sénat.fr et puis notez
notre prochaine invité politique dans la
matinale Oriane mansigny reçoit Roland
Lescure le ministre délégué en charge de
l'Industrie belle soirée à toutes et à
tous